[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
la pregunta del año es pues de europa
sobrevivir sin el gas ruso y la
respuesta a esta pregunta pasa por una
noticia que ha pasado prácticamente
desapercibida pero que es muy pero que
muy importante porque un día antes de
que putin entrar en ucrania tuvo esta
reunión el presidente ruso y el
azerbayano se reúnen hemos cuesta en
artes ya lo sé muchos pensaréis pero qué
tiene que ver el presidente de
azerbaiyán en esta historia pues mucho y
en el vídeo de hoy os vamos a hablar de
dos países que hasta ahora eran
prácticamente desconocidos pero que es
muy probable que pasan a dar mucho de
qué hablar en el futuro pero volvamos
con la pregunta del principio de verdad
de europa puede dejar de comprar gas
natural a rusia a estas alturas creo que
todos sabéis que europa necesita el gas
ruso para sobrevivir más del 40 por
ciento del gas natural que se consume en
toda la unión europea viene de rusia y
con o sin guerra en ucrania todo apunta
a que el kremlin quiere seguir vendiendo
de hecho mientras hacemos este vídeo con
los tanques rusos en las calles de kiev
los gasoductos de gazprom siguen
bombeando a la unión europea y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando todos en este
momento pero que sanciones económicas
podemos poner a rusia si después
seguimos comprando les el gas mientras
europa siga siendo el principal
comprador la economía rusa seguirá
recibiendo dinero
dicho de otra forma los políticos
europeos pueden seguir pronunciando
discursos dignos del mismísimo winston
churchill pero todo eso son eslóganes
baratos si seguimos financiando las
guerras de putin y precisamente han sido
los eslóganes baratos los que nos han
llevado a esta situación de hecho desde
que estalló la guerra en ucrania la
dependencia de rusia no ha hecho más que
crecer en europa y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando algunos hagamos el sacrificio
dejemos de comprarle gas a rusia si es
necesario pasaremos el resto del
invierno sin calefacción lo cierto es
que usamos el gas natural para todo
industria agricultura producción de
electricidad vamos que eso de hacerse el
mártir y decir que podemos vivir sin gas
natural hoy en día es otro eslogan
barato y creo que a estas alturas ya
estamos todos un poquito hartos de los
eslóganes baratos nos parece así que la
pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es de
verdad puede europa dejar de depender
del gas ruso existe alguna alternativa
en la política energética europea actual
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes muchos nos habéis preguntado
si existe una forma de colaborar con
ucrania en esta guerra y lo cierto es
que si el banco central de ucrania está
aceptando donaciones de todo el mundo
para apoyar la resistencia y las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas ojo esto no es una
inserción publicitaria nadie paga por
decir esto y es algo meramente
informativo si os interesa tenéis el
enlace en la descripción y ahora sí
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
pacto con el [ __ ]
voy a decirlo muy claro parte de lo que
está ocurriendo en ucrania ahora mismo
se debe a la política energética de
alemania y si ya sé que lo que acabo de
decir es muy controvertido pero los
datos están ahí hasta el momento en el
que hacemos este vídeo alemania ha
estado bloqueando el envío de armamento
a ucrania atentos a alemania de lo que
ya el envío de armas a ucrania en un
giro significativo en ayuda militar
hasta el sábado alemania tenía una larga
trayectoria de bloquear el envío de
armas letales a zonas de conflicto en
cualquier caso en todos los debates
sobre rusia-alemania siempre es el país
más próximo a las posturas del kremlin y
diréis pero por qué pues muy simple
porque al final de un largo camino de
eslóganes baratos está la realpolitik
más cínica me explico alemania es el
mayor consumidor de energía de toda
europa nuestros lógicos si tenemos en
cuenta que es la mayor economía de toda
la unión europea el problema de nuevo
los eslóganes baratos alemania no quiere
nucleares pero tampoco quiere carbón y
tampoco quiere petróleo y lo cierto es
que las energías verdes no son
suficientes a día de hoy no hay manera
de almacenar energía a nivel industrial
sí es cierto hay tecnologías
experimentales para almacenar energía
pero por el momento son cosas de
laboratorio y que nos queda el gas y por
eso tanto alemania como europa consumen
más gas natural que nunca
para que os hagáis una idea en 1990
producían en alemania- 40 mil gigavatios
de energía por gas en 2020 producían más
de 94 mil gigavatios es cierto que en
términos relativos el gas natural
representa un porcentaje menor en el mix
pero en términos absolutos cada vez
compran más y más gas y rusia es su
principal proveedor pensando así
políticamente hablando el gas ruso es el
bueno bonito y barato de la energía
bueno porque contamina menos que el
carbón bonito porque la energía siempre
que la necesitamos y barato porque viene
de los gasoductos de la madre rusia que
está cerca y tienen buenos precios
significa esto pactar con el [ __ ] pues
sí pero hasta ahora a quién le importaba
hemos visto un montón de manifestaciones
contra el cambio climático o contra la
energía nuclear pero quien se
manifestaba en contra de vladimir putin
no muchos
[Música]
vamos a decirlo claro hasta febrero de
2022 putin y la guerra de ucrania era
algo que preocupaba a los que veis
visual política y a4 más nadie en
alemania perdía elecciones por llevarse
been computing de hecho todos hemos
visto a raúl gonzález jugando en el
schalke con la camiseta de gazprom y a
nadie le ha parecido mal y todo esto
explica que en lugar de efectivamente
buscar otros proveedores de gas alemania
ha estado buscando formas de comprar aún
más gas a la madre rusia sin que éste
tuviera que pasar por ucrania injusto
pues sí pero de nuevo quien había oído
hablar del nord stream 2 hasta ahora y
así es como llegamos a febrero del año
2022 qué pasa ahora pues atentos
[Música]
una deuda con el [ __ ]
la primera consecuencia de la guerra con
ucrania es que el nord stream 2 se ha
paralizado hasta nueva orden creedme que
no ha sido una decisión fácil para
alemania pero lo cierto es que no
quedaba otra por el momento rusia sigue
vendiendo gas natural a europa a través
de ucrania la pregunta es hasta cuándo y
en qué condiciones atentos a lo que
decía el vicepresidente del consejo de
seguridad ruso dmitri medvédev en
twitter el canciller alemán olaf scholz
ha enviado una orden para parar el
proceso de certificación del norte
string dos bien bienvenidos a un nuevo
mundo donde los europeos tendrán que
pagar dos mil euros por mil metros
cúbicos de gas natural dmitri medvédev
vicepresidente del consejo de seguridad
de rusia la pregunta ya no es si
queremos seguir dependiendo de rusia la
pregunta es cómo reducimos ese 40% de
gas que compramos a rusia y cómo podemos
hacerlo lo antes posible por el momento
eeuu ya ha enviado más de 60 barcos
metaneros con gas natural liquado qatar
también ha dicho que estaría dispuesta a
vender algo de gas si rusia llegara a
cortar el suministro y diréis pues ya
está problema resuelto pues no para nada
mi entrada es muy difícil pensar que
tanto eeuu como qatar pudieran suplir
todo el gas que nos llega desde rusia
pero no sólo eso el gas natural licuado
es mucho más caro que el gas que llega
por el gasoducto si de repente esas
grandes fábricas europeas tuvieran que
pagar el gas a precios de asia
hablaríamos de una crisis económica
gigantesca y la pregunta es qué se puede
hacer volver a construir reactores
nucleares y lo cierto es que no parece
muy viable hacen falta casi 10 años para
construir un reactor nuclear y eso por
no hablar de la poca voluntad política
que existe en esta materia otra opción
podría ser
esperábamos a que las energías
renovables se puedan almacenar de forma
barata verdad y yo os he dicho yo de los
eslóganes baratos de verdad vamos a
tomar decisiones basándonos en la
promesa de que algún día alguien en
algún lugar descubrirá una nueva
tecnología que lo cambiará todo y diréis
entonces qué opciones tenemos en la mesa
pues atentos
[Música]
nuevos diablos con los que pactar
ya lo hemos dicho al principio la era de
los eslóganes baratos se ha terminado
así que vamos a empezar a llamar las
cosas por su nombre a europa no le queda
otra que pactar con nuevos diablos pero
pensadlo así es mejor depender de varios
diablos que de uno solo así que el
primer [ __ ] de nuestra historia es
este señor que vemos en pantalla
[Música]
os presento a él ham alíyev el
presidente de azerbaiyán ya los
azerbaiyán es uno de sus países que
descubres que existen gracias al
festival de eurovisión
pero creedme se trata de una dictadura
salvaje corrupta y no exenta de sus
problemas geopolíticos de los que ya
hemos hablado en otros vídeos si no que
se lo pregunten a los armenios y aquí es
donde encaja la noticia con la que
empezábamos este vídeo el presidente
ruso y el azerbayano se reúnen hemos
cuesta en artes está reunión se produjo
dos días antes de la invasión de ucrania
tanto putin como la jep se declararon
amor eterno o cooperación militar y
entendimiento de todo tipo la pregunta
es de verdad azerbaiyán es el mejor
aliado de rusia pues lo cierto es que no
de entrada compiten con moscú por vender
el gas pero no sólo eso el principal
apoyo militar de azerbaiyán es turquía
miembro de la otan desde 1952 y
antagonista histórico de rusia porque si
mis queridos amigos de la comunidad de
visual política además de ser famosos
por el caviar azerbaiyán está bendecido
con uno de los mayores yacimientos de
gas natural del mundo los famosos campos
del shah deniz que están en mitad del
mar caspio es más desde el año 2020
azerbaiyán ya está vendiendo gas natural
a europa atentos a este mapa
[Música]
aquí podéis ver como el gas viaja desde
el mar caspio hasta el sur de italia se
empezó a construir en mayo de 2016 y se
terminó de construir en noviembre de
2020 en total 4 años en su día este
gasoducto generó muchísima polémica y si
la propaganda rusa y los eslóganes
baratos del kremlin se implicaron al
máximo en italia incluso consiguieron
que el movimiento 5 estrellas que por
entonces era el partido político de moda
estuviera de su lado pero seamos
honestos nada que trascendiera la
opinión pública de hecho todos hemos
visto activo justo a ganando la liga con
el atlético de madrid- llevando la
camiseta de azerbaiyán land of fire y
nadie ha protestado nunca pues bien
gracias a este gasoducto hoy en día
europa puede diversificar aún más el
suministro
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando pues
menuda jugada de verdad vamos a
sustituir a un terrible dictador por
otro terrible dictador es decir vamos a
pasar a depender de rusia para depender
de azerbaiyán pues no tranquilos porque
en el selecto club de dictadores con
recursos naturales hay un nuevo jugador
alguien que nadie se esperaba y creerle
estoy seguro de que ninguno de vosotros
se la veía venir
[Música]
y el [ __ ] tonto
os presento a türkmenistán este país ni
siquiera participa en eurovisión y si os
suena tal vez sea por un vídeo que
hicimos en visual política hace varios
años que parecía más un monólogo de
humor que otra cosa de hecho es un vídeo
que tiene un montón de visitas porque es
tan terrible que hasta hace gracia el
dictador de este país se llama esperad
que el nombrecito se las trae
gurbanguly berdimuhamedov también
conocido por su perdido pueblo como
arcadas pues bien el señor arcadas es la
versión cómica de kim jong-il
para que os hagáis una idea se hizo
construir una estatua de oro de 21
metros de alto donde sale montando a
caballo en realidad las estatuas de
bronce pero está recubierta de oro de 24
quilates si tener una estatua dorada a
ti mismo no es suficiente también mandó
construir una a su perro además arcadas
también componen sus propias canciones
de rap y da conciertos a su pueblo esto
no es una broma ni una exageración si no
fuera porque hablamos de uno de los
regímenes más opresivos del mundo
parecería un capítulo de south park
sin embargo urban instant tiene atentos
las cuartas reservas de gas natural más
grandes del mundo y su único comprador
importante en este momento es china
durante varios años han intentado
construir un gasoducto para poder vender
a la india este gasoducto se llama el
tap tap y son las siglas de türkmenistán
afganistán pakistán y la india y si
habéis oído bien el futuro económico de
turbo instant dependía de un gasoducto
que iba a pasar por afganistán como os
podéis imaginar eso es un futuro
bastante incierto en estos momentos no
digo que no se vaya a construir pero
entenderéis que en estos momentos
intentar construir cualquier cosa en
afganistán es una tarea harto difícil
dicho de otra forma enseñar arcadas era
un dictador pero tiene gas natural y
está desesperado por venderlo y esto
explica noticias como esto el acuerdo
entre azerbaiyán y türkmenistán allanó
el camino para el gasoducto transcaspio
exacto si recordáis en aquel vídeo que
publicamos sobre türkmenistán ya os
decíamos que este país tenía gas natural
a manos llenas pero dábamos por hecho
que ese gas nunca podría llegar a europa
sin embargo la desesperación agudiza el
ingenio y la solución ya está sobre la
mesa
[Música]
sólo hace falta conectar el gas de
türkmenistán al gasoducto que ya conecta
a azerbaiyán con italia igual a europa
estará conectada con las cuartas mayores
reservas de gas natural del mundo a todo
esto hay otra ventaja con la que cuenta
türkmenistán atentos al mapa
veis lo mismo que yo sí exacto
türkmenistán compite con russian al
mercado del gas natural pero no tiene
fronteras con rusia es decir que es un
país difícil de invadir y diréis la
verdad es posible empezar a construir
plantas de extracción de gas natural en
türkmenistán pensad que hablamos de uno
de los lugares más subdesarrollados del
mundo además se trata de una dictadura
salvaje donde la seguridad jurídica
brilla por su ausencia pero seamos
claros si hay voluntad política todo es
posible y en estos momentos es cuando
conviene recordar que arabia saudita
hace 100 años no estaba mucho mejor que
türkmenistán hoy en día
[Música]
por supuesto todo esto no significa que
europa vaya a dejar de comprar gas a
rusia ni tampoco que conseguir nuevos
proveedores vaya a solucionar todos los
problemas energéticos que tenemos en
este continente pero si muestra que con
voluntad política se puede empezar a
reducir la rosa' dependencia de forma
efectiva y esto es algo urgente así que
la pregunta es de verdad habrá voluntad
política esta vez de verdad veremos a
europa haciendo una política clara para
dejar de depender de rusia de una vez
por todas creéis que esto es una buena
idea y lo que es más importante veremos
al barcelona poniendo una foto de la
estatua dorada de arcada nuestro querido
líder en sus camisetas podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que aquí en
visual politics sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribiros a
este canal y dadle la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones nos ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]